this is super interesting and very much
worth
spending some time on today there is a
guy named alex
berenson alex berenson is not a doctor
but has been front and center throughout
the pandemic
making tons of claims about the virus
about the pandemic itself about
containment guidelines
about masks vaccination the spread of
the virus
he has been wrong on essentially
everything
there is a very good article you can
read about him
in the atlantic called the pandemic's
wrongest man
just some of his greatest hits include
blaming vaccines
for more coronavirus cases suppressing
the immune system
uh saying israel suffered from being
early to vaccinate
that the vaccine side effects are worse
than
covet itself for anybody other than
seniors i i could go on and on i mean
he's just been wrong about everything i
can't think of anybody who's been this
wrong
maybe trump right but but it just
weaponized
uh uh wrongness is what i would call it
he is also a big anti-cannabis guy
very much against marijuana he's even
written books about how bad marijuana is
the books are trash they're filled with
anecdotes and
cherry-picked so-called data so
yesterday alex berenson goes on tucker
carlson i guess tucker has a new daytime
show it's a second show called
tucker carlson today you can distinguish
the shows because on his
nighttime show tucker's wearing a tie on
his daytime show
tucker is not wearing a tie i watched
a two-minute clip tucker and alex
berenson talking about
cannabis i was actually stunned at how
much
incorrect information is squeezed
into such a short period of time there
must be some record here for falsehoods
per minute
let's just jump right into it and and
start seeing if we can understand what's
going on
immunity will acknowledge that cannabis
can cause you know a fair number of
people especially
if you use heavily to have kind of
short-term
psychotic reactions right a bad trip but
they're peaceful though because
marijuana makes you
peaceful yeah it's the mahatma gandhi
drug that's right
that's right that's why that's why
violence has gone down
so much in the united states the last
five years okay so you heard
berenson there sarcastically say you
know if marijuana made
people mellow and docile violent crime
has gone down the last five years
implying violent crime is actually up
over the last
five years now there is a reason he says
in the last five years
because crime in the united states big
picture has been on the decline for a
really long time if you look at fbi data
for violent crimes per 100 000 people
violent victimizations per thousand
people age
12 or over property crimes per 100
000 people property victimizations per
thousand households they have
all been down down down over the last 28
years or longer
now it is true that with some indicators
the decline
sort of slowed down maybe even went up
and then back down over the last five to
seven years
it's been a less steady trend alex
berenson
apparently wants you to think that
because of marijuana law
crime is now going up because marijuana
does not actually make people docile it
makes people
violent every aspect of this claim is
wrong
first there's no evidence that marijuana
makes people violent
second we started seeing
decriminalization of cannabis
in 1973 medical cannabis legalization in
1996
recreational cannabis legalization in
2012 that's already nine
years ago so even the timeline he
implies
a causality for which there's no
evidence and he also
points to a timeline that doesn't
actually correlate with cannabis law
uh violent crime has been declining the
up and down period
doesn't correlate with cannabis uh law
changes it's just vapid
let's watch a little bit more of this so
you think that there is i mean i'm just
being completely honest i grew up in
southern california i spoke marijuana as
a child
everyone i knew believed that it
mellowed you out
right so you're saying there's evidence
of the opposite oh yeah there's i mean
again
so this is there's something called
cannibal cannabinoid hyperemesis
syndrome okay what that basically means
is uncontrolled vomiting
as a result of thc yes i've seen now
cannabis is supposed to settle you
settle your
stomach you know if you're nauseated
smoke some right that was sort of one of
the famous uses of it of course
for chemotherapy or chemo patients
that's right but it looks like there's
this paradoxical effect if you use too
much of it that for whatever reason
somehow resets the receptors in the
brain
for some people and they have this just
terrible uncontrolled vomiting that in
some cases can actually kill
there's i'm not exaggerating because you
become so dehydrated
it can kill you if you're not careful if
you don't get to an emergency room okay
now did you see what he did there
first he says there's this thing called
cannabinoid hyperemesis syndrome
where super high intake of thc
in some people could cause
uncontrolled vomiting now that part is
true that exists
and with countless substances
medications
you can have one effect at a normal dose
and the opposite effect at a
cartoonishly
high dose there's no question of that
that's not specific to thc
it's insanely rare with thc
uh but it is not exclusive uh to thc
then he says well it can kill you
if you become super dehydrated from the
vomiting and you don't go to a hospital
and deal with the dehydration
we're no longer talking about cannabis
so understand the game that he's playing
here
anything that causes you to become
dehydrated if you don't deal with the
dehydration
you could die and if you are
uncontrollably vomiting for a long time
then you should be going to the hospital
regardless of whether it's as a result
of extremely
cartoonishly high thc intake so
he mixes something that could happen
to someone who consumes an insane amount
of thc
but then he's admitting the risk isn't
actually from the cannabis it's anything
that causes uncontrollable vomiting
and subsequent dehydration it could be a
stomach bug could be food poisoning
could be for a whole bunch of other
reasons
he's sort of slick but it doesn't take
very long
to see through the nonsense let's just
watch
a little bit more um so
so paradoxically you know so in the
short term marijuana can reduce anxiety
certainly and it can get you high but
it like most anti-anxiety drugs you can
have bad rebound anxiety
if you try to quit i mean that's true of
benzodiazepines that's a known risk
okay further cannabis has this
effect on people where it makes them
paranoid some people
some of the time okay and if you have
this predisposition or if you're sliding
into mental illness
and you start smoking a lot you may sort
of temporarily muffle
that anxiety at the cost of your
paranoid symptoms getting worse
okay so again now he's talking about
some people get
side effects that are rare and may be
counterproductive to what you're trying
to treat
you might take cannabis for anxiety and
it makes you paranoid which then makes
you more anxious yeah that's true
this is the case with ssris for
depression and anxiety
which in some people short term medium
term you take an ssri
for anxiety it might cause anxiety you
take it for depression it could make
your depression worse
this is not new it's not unique to
cannabis
so it's if you actually go through it
it's a worthless segment there is
nothing of substantive value here
and increasingly the right is holding up
alex berenson
as some kind of brilliant truth-teller
who we should listen to because
everybody else is lying to us
but alex berenson is telling us the
truth increasingly a dangerous guy
and increasingly being held up as a hero
by right-wing media we'll have more
about this on the show's instagram page
make sure you're following us there
at david pakman show and you can follow
me on instagram at david.pacman
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a life saver and here's how it
works takes just a couple of minutes to
set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plug-in let you give
each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create out of thin air it'll
even autofill the card number with one
click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because you
can destroy
the virtual card number right after
using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank
or credit card info protected against
data breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like i said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at
privacy.com slash pacman